okay prenuptial agreements you're about
to get married right you just proposed
to your girl okay yeah
that's fantastic out of all the places
in the world right as that's you say
muzzle tough yeah thank you cnn has some
advice for you okay cnn
prenuptial agreements aren't just for
the rich here's what you should know few
people get married thinking they're
going to get divorced or about divvying
up money or assets after marriage ends
but more brides and grooms to be are
considering that scenario especially
when it comes on to prenuptial
agreements
these agreements are not just for the
wealthy and powerful 62 person of
divorce attorneys said they saw an
increase in clients requesting a prenup
with a significant uptick in millennials
signing them in general prenups can be
helpful for couples in which there's an
existing
existing wealth imbalance or there might
be one later on even if people aren't
wealthy now some clients have reasons to
believe they will be for example if
they're in a medical school
or accept expect an inheritance or other
reasons what are your thoughts on what
cnn
is saying which by the way i'm surprised
cnn wrote this article what are your
thoughts on cnn saying prenuptial
agreements are good i think this is what
happens when you take god out of
marriage i think this is what you have
when you have a secular society that
that doesn't value marriage as an
institution between a man a woman of god
or
people who are creating god's image it's
when you have a society that is built
totally just on again the politics and
these types of worldly possessions and
things it tells you that oh hey you know
you there's a pretty good chance that
you're not going to stay together this
this agreement that you're making with
your significant other isn't sacred it's
nothing that's really that important you
can end it at any time and it's not a
big deal and you know you should sign
and make sure that you get your money so
i think that
it's telling people
that you don't need to stay together you
don't need to work out your problems you
don't need to to toughen up and get
through it just end it you know who
cares just end it screw your kids and
and and the the covenant you made with
god all this just screw it and and move
on
i think that's i think it's bad would
would you get a prenup before you get
married no you would not i don't think
so no all right you don't think so so
he's considering to think so it's like
maybe a little bit there's like a
percentage ten percent changes
oh man look at that look honestly
she's gonna watch this you know well
yeah yeah
you're gonna have to have this tough
talk anyway we gotta cut the spark title
we gotta cut the spotlight exactly no i
i can we can we focus right on well
right now
can you see the sweat going down my face
yeah no i i think it's you know probably
like a 90 10 yeah you would not but i
wouldn't what happens if she goes i'd
like to get a freedom
i don't think that's going to happen if
she does we can have that discussion but
you know again in our point of view with
how we are as a couple it's like the man
okay would lead on these guys you're
gonna discuss this though with her right
yeah i'm sure we'll discuss it and
everything but as well home record it
hasn't even started yet i know
if you think this is a comfortable
conversation you have it with your wife
it's going to get worse so how about you
if you get that i did have a prenup and
i my marriage didn't work and thank god
i had the prenup because i had all the
money right so and i told her i'm not
marrying you unless i get the printer
she goes yeah that's fine yeah and do
you think that having that that prenup
makes it not just with you but in
general makes it so that people feel
more
safe getting divorces
i think that's an interesting
perspective i think you know everyone
needs an exit strategy so it's an exit
strategy yeah i think
because i think people get divorced too
easily well maybe you're right yeah
i got it tomorrow's very easy don't
worry about that yeah
i was in a i was enough i probably
should have gotten married at the time
but yeah now i had a will smith thing
going on um
but
i will say look numbers don't lie 50 of
marriages end in divorce
99 of relationships don't work out right
meaning like how many relationships do
you have before you end up getting
married and then the marriage doesn't
work
so
i look
if you have money
you know you want to throw god in the
equation and the holy trinity sister
whatever a rabbi like
there's a chance something's going to go
wrong right and
if you're worth a couple million bucks
and your wife ain't worth nothing and 10
years later she's worth a couple million
bucks and you're worth nothing that
doesn't sit well with you bro right okay
that's definitely true but again it goes
back to you know if you are it's about
people being more dedicated to marriage
you have to instill better values in
people which is very difficult to do of
course i love you know i'm giving best
case scenarios on what i if you're 25
women
i feel like
like i respect him like as a man but i
also think like like he's like a little
brother like right
like i get it you know what i'm saying
like right so of course
i do have any advice as like i think i
look at pat as like a
mentor big brother friend yeah you know
so
do you have advice for the kids out
there with friends i believe in prenups
i fully believe in prenups because
uh
you have to you you can
you can be held responsible for you
changing which you will but you have to
protect yourself against somebody else
who chooses to change because you're not
god so for me prenup is about you not
acting like your god that's actually
more
uh of a
i'm not god to say well
this is 100 gonna work then you're
saying you're god because you control
the other person i'm not god i don't
control my wife my wife gets to do
whatever she wants to do but a prenup to
me was protecting her she knew what was
going to be taking care of the kids
where she didn't have to worry about
anything and we put it together and
she's happy we're happy and it's good to
go i think prenups uh actually eliminate
arguments because sometimes people have
thoughts about what the other person's
motive is if you have a prenup in place
it's eliminated because that motive is
on the paper what can you do like a
trust a living trust and estate planning
all these things that you got to do
every business deal i've done with a
handshake dude i love you man it's
awesome we already right home
two years later that guy's no longer
working and you're carrying the weight
for the company and the guys goes to
costa rica for nine months and i have to
carry it away for the office i'm like
[ __ ] i never put that in the contract so
i have to do my part and i gotta pay
this guy and i got
man i wish i had that in the business
agreement i didn't do it so so you know
and relationships friendships marriages
people change i believe people change
and the biggest insurance policy of you
not being god and knowing that if people
change your protector she's protected as
a prenup if you enjoyed this short clip
click over here to watch another short
clip and if you want to watch the entire
episode the entire podcast click here
[Music]